[Music]
your job on the client list you're
you're wearing a lot of lingerie on that
show and you're giving massages to men
yeah and I'm just curious when you're on
set and you're do you have to really
give someone a massage while they're
shooting the scenes because when I'm
watching it seems like you're really in
there giving them a massage well here's
the thing no I don't think that I'm
actually supposed to but most of the
actors who come are always like you know
it would really help me in this scene if
you if you actually gave me a massage
and I'm thinking myself it would really
help me to be a better actor if somebody
was massaging me 24 school [ __ ] the guy
is just like it would help my process
help me be part of this scene if you rub
your hands all over I had a guy who was
like you know what I'm having a little
problem over here my shoulder and if you
could just like press on it a lot while
we're doing the scene it'll really help
me out and I'm like are you kidding me
okay fine there's my elbow no the answer
is no you're the star of the show okay
you know I feel bad and there I am in
like laundry it's so weird very weird
this is interesting you're in lingerie
you also direct episode how do you
direct an episode where you're also
appearing in at the same time you're
wearing because I also mean I really get
into the directing thing like I love it
and it just it makes me so happy and so
I just I get like into it and I just
directed an episode that aired not too
long ago and I was in a like a wig and a
full lace up corset with like a little
g-string and garters and 6-inch heels
that's how our director dresses yeah I'm
like sani and I'm like in the middle of
a second I'm like all right everybody
we're you know we're running out of time
I was gonna you know do this that I'm
sort of looking around and I'm like they
are not listening to anything nor are
they taking me seriously see that's the
other thing I would listen to everything
you were saying I would be the most
attentive person if you were talking to
me that way but you enjoy you should
accompany a client on the show
[Applause]
you wouldn't even know it yes I can
you're giving it to anybody who asks so
yes I would be lying down on my face
would be in a fast cradle no you'd be
laying back and we'd be shooting your
abs the goal here is that the goal here
is for you to get more people watching
your show I think you'd be great okay
all right me sorry yeah and I'll be face
to face up in and and I'll rub your abs
and you'll tell me is that we'll do many
takes we'll do many tapes my processes
we'll try it many different ways to get
it just right